Joe Biden vows to free hundreds of
thousands of prisoners the Epstein
allegations blowback on both Bill
Clinton and the Trump administration and
President Trump's poll numbers actually
rise I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
man we have a lot to get to today mr.
bata oh he's back on the road and now he
says that all of America is evil and
racist which is why a white man like
beta O'Rourke should be President of the
United States very important he'll also
get to Megan Rapinoe who is making the
rounds as the new woke voice of the left
and she's very very important because
she kicks a soccer ball and because she
kicks a soccer ball very well and this
means that she knows all there is to
know about politics and also about media
and also about everything she's like
Colin Kaepernick except more inspiring
we'll get to more of that a little bit
later on in the show we begin at this
hour
with Joe Biden really blowing up his
candidacy it's amazing to watch if you
look at the polls right now Joe Biden
continues to maintain a fairly solid
lead in the actual primary polling so
right now if you look at that Real Clear
Politics poll average which is the only
one that really matters at this point
because it's so early when Joe Biden is
leading the rest of the field by an
average of about 12 points that would be
the last 10 polls there's an economist
YouGov poll that came out yesterday and
that showed him up only four points over
Elizabeth Warren but there was an
emerson poll that came out the day
before and showed him up 15 points over
Elizabeth Warren and the rest of the
field that economist YouGov poll had the
race currently at Joe Biden 22 Elizabeth
Warren 18 Kamala Harris 15 and Bernie
Sanders 12 is pretty obvious that Bernie
Sanders is starting to feel the effects
of Elizabeth Warren on his flank and he
is starting to drop voters to her well
Joe Biden instead of strongly
campaigning toward the middle and
maintaining his brand and basically
saying come get me guys come over here
and get me where 40% of the bases come
over here and find me instead he is
swiveling into what the rest of the
Democratic Party wants from him so he is
swiveling toward the quote unquote
majority of the Democratic base now it
is true that only a plurality of the
Democratic base is quote unquote
moderate it's true that a majority of
the Democratic base is probably what we
would call progressive maybe even
radical but that progressive base is
going to splinter
there's not one candidate for them to
rally around and in fact a moderate
candidate in the last few Democratic
presidential cycles has actually seemed
to do better in the primaries than the
person who's perceived as more radical
that was true in 2004 with
John Kerry it wasn't true in 2008 with
Barack Obama but that's because Barack
Obama followed the most simple rule of
American politics run against Hillary
Clinton that is the number-one rule of
American politics if you run against
Hillary Clinton in anything but in New
York Senate race you will win so 2008
was an example that that did not fall
toward moderation but obviously by 2016
Hillary Clinton was perceived as the
moderate against Bernie Sanders and she
ended up winning the nomination on those
grounds well Joe Biden has a strategy
his strategy is to embrace his record
and say yes it turns out that I am kind
of moderate it turns out that well I do
want to see change happen I don't think
that America is a terrible horrible no
good very bad place now this is opening
ad I know it feels like it's been years
but it's only been two and a half three
months since Joe Biden jumped into the
race
with an ad that he launched by talking
about the historic greatness of America
not about the historic evil of America
and then he is very quickly shifted over
to his left in an attempt to crowd out
the rest of the field instead he has
been sucked into the rest of the field I
think he was seeing this this race as
sort of an Indy 500 he was going to
swivel out toward the fire lanes drive
everybody into the wall instead what has
happened is he drove himself directly
into a car crash and now he's involved
in that car crash and he keeps getting
more and more radical in his commentary
and it ain't going to help him so let's
give an example yesterday Joe Biden
there's tape of him I guess this
happened on Sunday Joe Biden was asked
about cutting prison populations in the
United States now Joe Biden was
responsible for a crime bill in 1994 he
was a cosigner of it co-sponsor of it in
1994 that was dramatically helpful in
decreasing the crime rates around the
United States I know that we like to
forget history conveniently the fact is
between 1960 and 1994 we had one of the
greatest surges in crime in the history
of the United States probably the
greatest surge in crime violent crime in
the history of the United States murder
rates were at extraordinary highs in
most of America's major cities
they'd risen dramatically across the
country and in 1994 the federal
government decided that they were going
to crack down on a fair number of crimes
and provide new resources for policing
to states and localities and the crime
rate began a historic reversal
unprecedented
reversal the crime rates began to drop
in 1994 that continued to drop all the
way until the Ferguson effect reversed
them in 2014 2015 2016 and so that was a
good thing but Joe Biden is now being
forced to run away from his
quote/unquote moderate record he is now
being forced to run on the progressive
record and that progressive record is
supposed to be well it's free all the
prisoners let's let everybody out of
prison well then the nice thing about
saying let's let everybody out of prison
is that you never actually have to deal
with what happens when bunches of people
are let out of prison you get to pose
yourself as some sort of human rights
activist while allowing criminals to
wander free on the streets we've seen
this in the state of California Jerry
Brown the former governor in the state
of California he participated in
something called prison realignment
instead of providing new funding that
was necessary to keep prisoners in
prison he lowered sentences he
reclassified felonies as misdemeanors in
the violent crime rate has gone up in
the state of California at least in its
major cities I live in Los Angeles the
quality of life has gone down
dramatically with regard to everything
from street crime to violent crime as
well and drug crime to all of this is a
serious problem but we're supposed to
ignore it because we falsify the stats
it is very easy
aside from murder it's very easy to
falsify statistics when it comes to
crime statistics because police
departments will be told by mayor's that
they need to simply reclassify crimes in
different ways and report them
differently in order to artificially
lower the crime rates but you can tell
in terms of quality of life that
California has had a rough time since
prison realignment we're gonna get to
what Joe Biden had to say in just one
second it is fully insane because this
is where he thinks the Democratic Party
is it's like kind of Donald Trump back
in 2016 speaking conservatism as a
second language
Donald Trump has turned out to govern
pretty conservatively he doesn't know
much about conservatism and in 2016
Trump did this routine where he would
sort of estimate where he thought
conservatives lay and so when it came to
abortion for example he would say sure
let's prosecute
let's prosecute women for abortions that
is not the position of anyone in the
pro-life movement nor has it been for
decades but because Trump isn't familiar
with the pro-life movement he sort of
threw out what he thought they wanted to
hear now you got Joe Biden doing the
same thing with the woke brigade well
now he is going to try and pander to
people who are woke by throwing out
solutions that make no sense at all I'll
get to that in a second first it's a
hell of a lot easier listening to
pundits Duke it out over the latest
Washington whatever let's take a good
hard look at your own finances and a lot
of folks have gotten stuck in serious
credit card debt because they haven't
been looking at their own finances and
this is why you ought to be responsible
how can you do that well head over to
Lending Club with lending club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off your
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club calm you can tell
them about yourself how much you want to
borrow take the terms that are right for
you if you are approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
accounts in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club comm / Ben check that rate
in minutes borrow up to $40,000 that is
Lending Club com / Ben Lending Club comm
/ Ben all loans made by web bank member
FDIC Equal Housing lender no reason if
we'd get caught up in those 25 percent
30 percent credit card interest rates
instead go refi with Lending Club com /
been Lending Club calm / Banyan check
your rate borrow up to 40 grand Lending
Club com / Ben all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender ok
so Joe Biden is now out there
proclaiming that he wants to free
hundreds of thousands of prisoners now
this may be popular with folks on the
left it has never been popular in
American politics to say that you
actually want to free hundreds of
thousands of prisoners including violent
criminals this has never been popular
Rudy Giuliani became mayor of New York
New York as far left the city as it is
possible to have in the United States
Rudy Giuliani became a very popular
mayor of New York specifically on the
basis of quality of life issues and
crime in Los Angeles Mayor Richard
Riordan did something very similar
Governor Arnold Schwarzenegger was
basically elected not just because of
the Enron energy crisis out here in Los
Angeles and in California but also
because of issues with quality of life
if you want a Republican elected in a
country that is shifting some left all
you have to do is point to quality of
life George HW Bush in 1988 may have won
the election based on the perception
that Michael Dukakis was soft on crime
so I know that we are now living off the
boon off the bounty of a 25 year yes
when
five year drop in crime rates I
understand all of that but that doesn't
mean that the American people are
willing to see a reversal of the crime
rates based on violent criminals being
released from prison why am I making a
big deal out of this cuz it's not
getting any attention at all I'm shocked
by this I mean here's Joe Biden saying
he this is an insane Val here's Joe
Biden valent you cut the prison
population in the United States by more
than 50%
five zero percent excu has a roadmap for
cutting incarceration by 50% through
reforms that have been endorsed by both
the right and the left including four
other presidential candidates and many
conservatives let me show you committed
to cutting incarceration by 50 percent
if elected okay the answer the answer is
yes of course I'm gonna reduce prison
populations by more than 50% now there's
a lot of talk in the United States about
mass incarceration the reason people
talk about mass incarceration on the
Left particularly is because a
disproportionate number of people in
prison disproportionate to the
population statistics are minority
descent right our black and Hispanic and
this is supposedly a reference to
America's deep-seated criminal justice
racism well the reality is that
unfortunately a disproportionate number
of black and Hispanic people in the
United States are committing crimes as a
percentage of the population generally
and that is true from in everything from
murder statistics to violent crime there
are certain crimes where it's
disproportionately white that crystal
meth is a disproportionately white crime
people who are arrested for crystal meth
distribution are disproportionately
white there are certain types of
white-collar crime that are
disproportionately white but when you're
talking about violent crime if you're
talking about murder for example the the
people who are committing murder are
disproportionately of minority races now
that is not a referendum that is not a
statement about race innately being
linked to crime it is just pointing out
that if you are arresting a
disproportionate number of people from a
population group that is not necessarily
a reference to the racism of the system
that may be a reference to the people
who are actually committing the crimes
that's not the fall to the police that's
not the fault of the criminal justice
system so the amassing entire basis of
the
free hundreds of thousands of people
from prison argument is that the system
is inherently racist and therefore we
need to let hundreds of thousands of
people out and we're going to reduce
prison populations by fifty percent so
let's look at what the prison
populations of the United States
actually look like in terms of the
crimes they have committed I don't care
about the race of people in prison I
don't care about the race of people in
any industry I don't care about the race
of people in the United States generally
I'm not interested in the racial
demographics of the United States I care
much more about what people think and
what people do because I thought we were
supposed to not care about people's race
because that's called racism so instead
let's focus on what people have done to
get themselves in prison now we can all
agree if somebody is innocent and in
prison they should not be in prison and
we all agree on that so the question now
is which guilty criminals should we
allow to go free because that's what Joe
Biden's talking about he's not
suggesting that lots of innocent people
are in prison
he is suggesting that a lot of people
who have been convicted of actual crimes
ought to go free and he says more than
fifty percent should be released so
let's look at the actual percentages of
people who are in prison so first of all
the vast majority of people in prison
and by the vast majority I mean 13 out
of every 15 people who are in prison are
in state prisons not federal
penitentiaries and most crimes that are
committed in the United States are state
level crimes and most of those crimes
happened to be violent crimes contrary
to popular opinion the vast majority of
crimes for which people are in jail are
not people who are picketing who are
picked up for smoking dope on the street
that is simply not correct when you look
at the state prisons if this is
information from the prison policy
initiative which is a fairly left-wing
group on prison policy they have a solid
breakdown here if you're watching the
show that you can see this particular
chart is why I should subscribe state
prisons currently hold about 1.3 million
people seven hundred and twelve thousand
of those people are in prison for
violent crimes 137 thousand for assault
one hundred seventy two thousand for
robbery one hundred sixty-three thousand
for rape or sexual assault eighteen
thousand for manslaughter a hundred and
seventy nine thousand for murder
okay so that means the single largest
plurality of people who are in prison
for violent crime are in for murder so
that's a lot of people who ought to be
in prison it seems to me if you commit
an assault a robbery a rape or sexual
assault manslaughter or murder there's a
very solid case that you should be in
prison and that represents over half of
the people are in state prisons then
there are another 235
people who are in state prison for a
property crime and that would be fraud
burglary theft car thefts other property
that's that's a large share of folks
okay about two hundred thousand people
are in prison for drug for drug
possession for drug crimes the vast
majority of those people are not in for
drug possession first of all most of the
time when people are in prison for drug
possession it is because they pled down
from drug trafficking it's because the
drug dealer was picked up and then cut a
plea deal in which they pled guilty to
speed up the system and they went to
jail for drug possession which is a
lower sentence say their sentence
degraded I worked in a prosecutor's
office for a summer this is how it works
and the vast majority of those people
even the ones who plead guilty to drug
possession are not actually going to
jail for drug possession it is they pled
down offense other drug crimes represent
the vast majority as in seventy five
percent of all the people who are in
state prison for drug crimes and then
you have a hundred fifty one thousand
people who are in jail on the basis of
what they call Public Order offenses
which is for example weapons possession
possession of illegal weapons or driving
under the influence so which of those
people do you feel like ought to be
released according to Joe Biden half
those people ought to be released where
is that gonna come from and since over
half of those people are in prison for
violent crimes that means that if you
were to release everyone who is not in
prison for a violent crime on the state
level everyone that would still only
represent about 40% of the people who
are in state prison so you still have to
have another ten percent coming from
somewhere that means you would have to
release about a hundred and eighteen
thousand by this chart 118 thousand
violent criminals onto the streets of
the United States yeah he's gonna make
America a better place or a worse place
to have violent criminals walking around
okay so let's even assume that we're
talking about federal prisons and jails
so if you look at federal prisons and
jails what you see is that contrary
again to popular opinion the majority of
people who are in federal prison are in
federal prison for non drug offenses a
seventy five thousand people seventy six
thousand people according to the Bureau
of Prisons are in prison for drug
offensives that represents about forty
five percent of the total number of
people in the federal pen for drug
offenses again the vast majority of
those people are not in for drug
possession the vast majority of those
people are in for drug trafficking
meaning you have a drug dealer on the
street who is dealing to kids
right somebody who
who is importing coco cocaine into an
inner city and then dealing crack to
school kids or something a drug
trafficking is a serious crime now if
you want to make the case that we ought
to legalize drugs in the United States
you'll make the full libertarian case
that's a case I'm willing to hear but if
the case that you are making is that we
there's gonna be no negative impacts to
releasing drug traffickers back onto the
streets of the United States let's hear
that case gang I can I can see the cost
and the benefits of this particular case
but I'm not feeling that people are
making honest arguments about this sort
of stuff there will be costs to
releasing drug traffickers back onto the
streets those people are not generally
going to go get a job at the local
Walgreens many of those people are gonna
go right back to crime the recidivism
rate in the United States is
extraordinarily high the recidivism rate
in for many crimes in the United States
is upward of 75 or 80 percent
take for example California according to
a 2012 report by the California
Department of Corrections and
Rehabilitation more than 65% of people
released from California's prison system
are back in prison within three years
according to the national statistics on
recidivism is the the National Institute
of Justice reporting 60% of arrests
occurred during four during the years
four through nine an estimated 68
percent of all released prisoners were
arrested within three years 79 percent
within six years 83 percent within nine
years hey those recidivism rates are
incredibly incredibly high so let's not
pretend that these folks are gonna go
back to living a life of crime free
existence the vast majority of the mode
some of them will some of them will if
we could pick and choose which ones
would then there's a case for early
release for those people but if you are
just talking about blanket release of an
enormous number of people like Joe Biden
is apparently talking about releasing
half the prison population
good luck with all of that good luck
with all that but again this is not
directed toward anything remotely like a
policy that is workable Joe Biden
wouldn't do any of this as president
this is exactly like when Kamala Harris
is ripping into Joe Biden over
supposedly not backing forced busing and
then she was asked so do you support
forced busing and she's like nah not
really
and people should use it as a tool but
I'm not really not really going to
impose forced busing from above in other
words right now the Democratic Party
primary is a bunch of virtue signaling
and if people take that virtue signaling
as an actual platform they're going to
be scared to death which is the reason
that the polls for president Trump have
been rising consistently in the general
election numbers there's a very good
poll out for president Trump yesterday
from Emerson and it showed a bunch of
head to heads of Democrats now in most
of the head to heads prior to this Trump
had been in a little bit of trouble
against most of the Democrats although
there is a trend ok the trend is that
Trump is basically even with all the
Democrats except for Biden that is from
the two last polls there was an ABC
news/washington post poll that came out
on Sunday and here's what it showed
showed Biden 53 Trump 43 that one's the
outlier right and that is because Biden
is widely known he is perceived as a
moderate the further left he moves the
worse it is for him he's making himself
vulnerable with this sort of stupidity
but running against Kamala Harris Trump
is basically in a dead heat
it's Harris 48th Trump 46 according to
ABC News Washington Post it is Sanders
49 Trump 48 according to ABC News
Washington Post Warren and Trump tied at
48 Budaj edge and Trump tied at 47
according to the ABC news/washington
post poll from Sunday and then those
results are mirrored in the Emerson poll
so according to the Emerson poll Biden
is up 6 he's the only one with a clear
lead on Trump right now Trump actually
beats Kamala Harris by two according to
that poll he is he is behind by two to
Bernie Sanders 5149 he's at 51 against
Warren and 51 against Buddha judge in
other words he's hitting numbers that he
actually would need to hit in order to
retain the presidency this is because
the more people see of the Democrats the
more it's a referendum on their
radicalism having Joe Biden out there
proclaiming to the sky that he is going
to release hundreds of thousands of
prisoners onto America's streets
honestly if Trump doesn't run on that I
don't know what he's doing and I have a
feeling that Trump is certainly going to
run on the Democrats being
extraordinarily weak on crime everything
from their their willingness to to dump
hundreds of thousands of prisoners into
the American population to
decriminalizing illegal immigration
which is something they continue to push
to do there's something else that's been
happening I'm going to talk about in
just a minute and that is
this is push from the social left to get
corporations to do their bidding as well
what we are we are experiencing right
now is not merely a political
polarization it is a cultural
polarization that is leading to a
breakup in in the country I'm not
talking about like full-scale secession
but I'm talking about an increasing
feeling that we ought not live in the
same country that is burgeoning on the
left and then in response on the right
it's really bad I'm gonna explain in
just one second first we live in a world
where we have access to data that gives
us more personal insights into who we
are what's more personalized than your
DNA now we can turn to our genetics for
personalized health traits and more
23andme that's the name of this service
it allows you to go beyond ancestry to
access more personalized insights about
you based on your DNA I've taken the
23andme test turns out I'm 100%
Ashkenazi Jew 100% pure Ashkenazi Jew I
mean that's I didn't know how to
describe that except to say that
Ashkenazi Jews are famous for a couple
of things not great food and genetically
tay-sachs oh they'll be that one may
that's that is what I found out from 23
I mean I also found out about my muscle
composition how caffeine affects me all
sorts of good stuff 23andme and reveal
more about your sleep with their deep
sleep report if you've always suspected
that you feel more sleepy than others
after missing out on a night of sleep it
might not be that you're imagining
things your genes may actually be
involved check out their alcohol flush
reaction reports there's alcohol turn
your cheeks as pink as a glass of rose a
you may have alcohol flush reaction
which would be good to know if you're
not like a business setting learn about
the genetic factors you may have that
make it harder to process alcohol see
what your genes can say about your
health traits and more by your health
and ancestry service kit today at
23andme calm / appear oh that's the
number two three and me.com slash
Shapiro again 23andme comm slash apparel
and give them a try
alrighty so as I say the culture seems
to be coming apart so it is not merely
that politicians are polarizing because
its primary season and now they have to
appeal to the most radical among us now
there's pressure that is being put on
private industries to do the same you've
seen this with Nike going woke in order
not to go broke
but there's Nikes new strategy is that
they're going to be as woke as humanly
possible they're going to embrace Colin
Kaepernick they're going to suggest that
women are somehow put down in American
society
well now SunTrust a bank
has decided that they are not going to
be involved in the private prison
industry according to Forbes com
SunTrust Bank announced this morning
they are ready to join other major banks
and moving away from the private prison
industry in the wake of deep public
sentiments against their role in mass
incarceration and family detention sue
Milano chief communications officer
SunTrust Bank said quote following an
ongoing and deliberate process SunTrust
has decided not to provide future
financing to companies that manage
private prisons and immigration holding
facilities this decision was made after
extensive consideration of the views of
our stakeholders on this deeply complex
issue in other words a bunch of people
whined and suggest that it was very bad
to fund private prison complexes that
are necessary for keeping prisoners
there that it would be very bad to have
private detention facilities that allow
for you know more humane detention of
illegal immigrants in the United States
and so SunTrust is pulling out and we're
seeing this from other banks as well
we've seen Bank of America direct action
against particular groups that it does
not like and while you or I may agree on
the groups that they don't like it is
very bad policy to have banks rejecting
groups not based on a legal activity of
the groups but based on viewpoint
discrimination it's very bad for the
country now they can do what they want
they're a private industry but the
predictable result will be that there
will be alternative banks that spring up
to lend to a lot of these sorts of
industries and so what you will end up
with is banks that do not politically
discriminate and banks that do
politically discriminate and this is
happening in virtually every area of
corporate America and what the left has
realized for a while is that if they
pressure corporations to do something
corporations will likely do it that the
squeakiest wheel tends to get the grease
most of us don't really think about the
corporate messaging of the products that
we buy we just go and look for the best
products is particularly true for
conservatives we basically go and we
look for the best products we buy them
like I didn't care about Nikes politics
until the last five minutes because why
would I care about that
I need a shoe but there are a lot of
people on the Left who do not feel the
same way and they actually look to
corporations to mirror their social
justice preferences so if you are a
corporation and you feel no blowback
from the right when you go woke but you
feel lots of blowback from the left when
you do not go woke you are likely to
cater to the left well eventually the
right is gonna get wise to this and
they're going to stop buying Nike shoes
there's
going to stop banking with institutions
that they don't like or alternatively
they will be expelled from those
institutions because the only thing a
lot of the left wants is to ban all of
this stuff from entering the public
square at all they want to use the
corporation's as their tools they want
the corporation's to do their dirty work
for them that will lead to an
alternative market a resegregate of the
political market and sort of like how
this happened in news right you've seen
the daily where spring up on the right
and you got huffington post on the left
you're gonna see this happen with non
informational driven exchanges you're
gonna see this happen with bigger
corporations and that's actually very
bad for the country you're seeing this
happen right now with regard to with
regard to Home Depot Home Depot is being
boycotted and a lot of this is just
based on bad information it's based on
bad policy it's based on media coverage
that is not true I'll get to that in
just one second first be an adult being
an adult means that you sometimes have
to think about and do things that you
really don't feel like doing like those
red-eye flights or working late visiting
your in-laws getting life insurance
another part of adulthood is learning to
delegate what you hate
well you can't delegate that visit to
the in-laws you can certainly delegate
life insurance shopping policy genius
it's the easy way to shop for life
insurance online in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find it your best price it's super
important to have life insurance guys I
understand that you don't want to think
about your own death but once you've
gotten this taken care of you don't have
to think about it anymore
now you just know that your family is
covered in case god forbid something
happens over a policy genius once you
apply the policy genius team will handle
all the paperwork and the red tape that
means no sales pressure no hidden fees
just financial protection and peace of
mind policy genius doesn't just do life
insurance they can also help you find
the right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so if you need life
insurance but you don't want to deal
with all that legwork head on over to
policy genius com that's the easy way to
compare all the top insurers find the
best value for you that's policy genius
delegate what you hate especially if
what you really hate is getting life
insurance get it taken care of right now
it's policy genius.com so as I say the
pressure on these banks to divest from
the prison in the so called prison
industrial complex is coming from the
left a scowl writing for daily wire
yesterday points out that during the
first round of Democratic presidential
debates senator Elizabeth Warren slammed
private prisons and called for their
elimination she said our criminal and
immigration
systems are tearing apart communities of
color and devastating the poor including
children okay first of all arresting
criminals and taking them out of
communities is one of the things that
makes it easier to live in a community
and if you don't that this weird idea
that all these guys who are going to
prison for crimes are actually
responsible fathers and wonderful family
figures and then they just sort of get
randomly plucked up and put in prison
I'm not seeing a lot of evidence of this
in any case she claimed that the the
economy is benefiting a thinner and
thinner slice at the top and she noted
people who want to invest in private
prisons but this is not true private
prisons under President Trump have not
actually been doing very well core civic
which was formerly Corrections
Corporation of America is down about 25%
since Trump's inauguration GE Oh group
is down about 20% Bank of America and
SunTrust have have also announced they
would stop financing for-profit prisons
there's basically no evidence to suggest
that the private prison complex is doing
great under President Trump and is
benefiting from all of these crime
policies or any of that but again bad
information is more important than true
information so long as the bad
information gets broader play you're
seeing the same thing today with regard
to a boycott a so-called boycott of Home
Depot now it is important to note the
vast majority of people who say they're
gonna boycott these companies on the
Left never do any other stuff and how
many of the people who say they're gonna
boycott Home Depot actually shop at Home
Depot the answer probably none how many
of the people who say they're going to
blow back on SunTrust actually bank at
SunTrust I would bet very very very few
the truth is that boycotts have a long
failed history in the United States it
is very rare to see a successful boycott
the Montgomery bus boycott is one good
example of a successful boycott but it
is exorbitant ly rare today particularly
for a boycott to actually hurt a company
all you have to do is look at Nike a lot
of conservatives fulminating over Nike
and Colin Kaepernick their stock has
been up since the beginning of the year
dramatically Nike knows that that's why
they're smart enough to ignore the
detractors and just do what they want to
do and pander to the people they want to
pander to on the left
well apparently most corporations are
not that smart nonetheless people are
targeting home depot why well because
one of its founders Bernie Marcus has
said that he intends to support
president Trump's re-election campaign
and this means that a bunch of people
say that
are not going to actually shop at Home
Depot anymore well this is really stupid
because Burnie Marcus retired from Home
Depot 15 years ago and doesn't speak on
behalf of the company the company
doesn't endorse presidential candidates
so he still continues to own shares in
the business but he is not speaking on
behalf of Home Depot this is just as
dumb as the boycott of chick-fil-a based
on the political preferences of the
owners of chick-fil-a chick-fil-a caters
to customers of every every name every
kind every sexual orientation apparently
none of that matters all this is doing
is polarizing our culture and when we
continue in just a second I'm going to
show you how even the most anodyne silly
topics like women's soccer have become
incredibly polarized and polarized by
frankly celebrity figures who don't know
what the hell they're talking about
Megan Rapinoe would be today's key
example of a celebrity figure who does
not know what the hell she's talking
about
contradicts herself all over the place
and is feeded by the media for her
trouble because she obviously check some
intersectional boxes at first when you
work as much as I do sleep is vital I
don't tend to get enough of it and I'm
not alone did you know more than one in
three US adults does not get enough
sleep if you're not sleeping enough it
can affect your cognitive function
during the day learning problem solving
decision making that's why we've
partnered with comm the number one app
for sleep sleep deficiency does serious
damage not just your brain but your body
as well the sleep lists are most more
prone to accidents weight gain
depression with calm you'll discover a
whole library of programs designed to
help you get to sleep your brain and
body needs they have soundscapes over
100 sleep stories narrated by soothing
voices like Jerome Flynn from Game of
Thrones and Stephen Fry so if you want
to seize the day you got to sleep
tonight with the help of clump I use
comma myself and I can't fall asleep I
just put on the app and I am out like a
light right now
then Shapiro listeners get 25% off a
calm a premium subscription now calm
calm slash pen @c alm calm slash been
forty million people have downloaded
calm already there is a reason check
them out at calm calm slash man by the
way they also have great solutions for
your kids not being able to fall asleep
go check them out at com.com slash been
in just a second we're gonna get to
Megan Rapinoe
astonishing interview on Anderson Cooper
last night first you're gonna have to go
subscribe over at daily we're calm $9.99
a month gets you a subscription to daily
wire calm but more importantly there's
something very
for you over at Daily wire calm in the
very near future and also you'll be able
to download it from our from our app and
everything this month marks the 50th
anniversary since we first put a man on
the moon and we have a brand new
exciting podcast called Apollo 11 what
we saw the host is Bill Whittle he's an
author pilot space enthusiasts he knows
more about NASA than any person I've
ever met he takes you on the journey of
what it took to get to the moon and what
happened when we got there and how
things almost went horribly horribly
wrong head over to Apple podcast right
now or wherever you listen to podcasts
and subscribe today to Apollo 11 what we
saw again it's called a Powell 11 what
we saw it is the entire story of Apollo
11 the mission that put a man on the
moon it is super cool I mean it is just
terrific and also you're gonna want to
follow us over at YouTube because the
visuals on this thing are really
astonishing I mean we did some amazing
work on the visuals for Apollo 11 what
we saw but if you're just a listener
then go subscribe over at Apple podcasts
to Apollo 11 what we send your search in
the search bar for it'll pop right up
hit subscribe and then as soon as the
episodes start arriving I promise you
it's addictive it is so good I've
listened to some of it it's amazing
check it out Apollo 11 what we saw okay
also go subscribe to our website over
daily where dot-com $9.99 a month or 99
bucks a year for the annual with the
annual you get among other things this
the very greatest in beverage vessels
the leftist cheers how to call tumblr
you've heard me talk about it before but
you've not experienced the joy yourself
until you actually grasp it in your paw
go check it out right now at leftist
tears that leftist year's hot or cold
temblor daily wire calm we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so talking about cultural polarization
it's funny the moments that are supposed
to be unifying for the country are no
longer unifying for the country so the
Women's World Cup team wins the World
Cup and as I have said I don't care
about this other than I like America
I'll root for America whether we are
winning in curling or whether we are
women and women winning in badminton or
women soccer I really don't care I have
no particular love for soccer generally
I certainly have no particular love for
women's soccer mainly because I care
about skill level and women's soccer is
just not at the same skill level as
men's soccer I mean really not even as
teenage boys soccer in many cases in any
case this has become a big deal that's
fine that's fine but what made it
political is that many on the u.s.
women's national team decided that they
were now going to be social justice
heroes and this meant that they were
going to stump for so-called equal pay
now as we've talked about on the program
this is a bunch of crap women do not
deserve equal pay in the World Cup with
the men they do not earn as much money
they do not sell as many tickets that is
simply a fact when it comes to the US
soccer US national soccer you know like
on in non World Cup years then there's
maybe a case that women should be paid
more but guess what they have collective
bargaining rights and they collectively
bargained for a contract two years ago
so if they did a bad job negotiating
that would be on them also it is true
they don't sell as many tickets overall
as the men particularly when you include
World Cup years when you include World
Cup years men dramatically outsell the
women like by ten million dollars okay
so all of this has been a bunch of
nonsense even the the sort of more
left-wing publications The Washington
Post the New York Times that have been
calling for quote-unquote equal pay
recognize that women have not actually
earned equal pay on the World Cup stage
but they just wanted anyway
so this has been their thing the lead
voice in this has been Megan Rapinoe now
Megan Rapinoe has basically been since
2016 doing the Colin Kaepernick routine
getting famous off the off the radical
left social justice stuff that she has
been pushing then that's the reason why
she's really being celebrated today not
because she's a terrific soccer player
which she apparently is but because she
is an outspoken lesbian because she is a
very outspoken sjw on so-called
equal pay issues even though again she's
not really something for equal pay she's
something for disproportionate pay from
women on the basis of media coverage
effectively and she has become this sort
of obnoxious advic
for her position the reason I call it
obnoxious is because I'm sorry but if
you go to University of Portland on
scholarship for women's soccer and then
you're whining about this country shut
up hey really this is a pretty great
country when you get to go to college
for free because not only do you kick a
ball you kick a ball any sport people
pretend to care about once every four
years and when I say shut up by the way
I don't mean that she should be made to
be quiet she can talk as much as she
wants I'm just saying it's obnoxious
because guess what it is obnoxious when
she's kneeling for the national anthem
in a country that is celebrating her as
a heroine she yet she's getting paid
millions of dollars to make ads for Nike
about how she is a lesbian and outspoken
and a soccer player it seems to me
should be sort of grateful for the
country that makes all that possible and
seems to me you should be pretty happy
about the country not sitting back and
talking about how terrible the country
is all the time more than that Rapinoe
demonstrates an obvious unwillingness to
even talk with anybody on the other side
of the aisle now before people say why
don't you talk with you you're
criticizing her right I'm criticizing
her specifically because she has
evidence no desire to have conversation
of any merit or substance on these
issues instead she appears on media
outlets that drool over her and ask her
silly stupid questions and allowed her
to get away with silly stupid answers so
I want to give you a couple of examples
of how Megan Rapinoe is being treated
and how she says dumb things on a
regular basis and nobody calls her out
on it because again her intersectional
credentials are in order because even
though she grew up from what I
understand middle to upper-class right
when she was playing soccer from the
time she was five years old she went to
I believe a private high school I'm not
sure she went to eat I know that she was
playing on the on the junior soccer
circuit and all of this she's lived a
pretty good life in the United States I
think it's fair to say Megan Rapinoe has
lived a pretty good life in the United
States still she talks about how America
is really really a bad place and then
she also suggested that she didn't want
to meet with people I mean it was really
amazing she said she did not want to
meet with people who disagree with her
so here she is giving a shout out to
Alexandra Ocasio cortes because this is
the kind of is what we're talking about
here I know you've been invited about I
think congresswoman Alexandra Cosmo
Cortez I think Nancy Pelosi
so does that mean is that an image
you're taking up I think everyone is
interested in going to Washington I
think we've always been interested in
going to Washington this is such a
special moment for us and to be able to
you know sort of leverage this movement
talk about the things that we want to
talk about and to celebrate like this
with the leaders of our country is an
incredible moment okay and then she
continued by suggesting that she didn't
want to meet with the Trump
administration so instead of everybody
celebrating together or maybe her making
her point to you know people who
disagree maybe she could make an
affirmative case and said she says she's
not going to meet with the
administration because she doesn't want
to be co-opted or used by the
administration yes I am sure that that
would have been the media coverage is
Megan Rapinoe co-opted by President
Trump it wouldn't have been her going to
the White House and then mouthing off to
Trump about equal pay or something that
which is exactly what would have
happened right that would have been
honestly if I were her media advisor
that's what I would tell her to do
accept the invitation from the Trump
White House go there and then make a
comment directly to Trump's face about
equal pay right that that would be the
smartest thing for ado she's not gonna
do that yeah I don't think I don't think
anyone on the team has any interest in
lending the platform that we've worked
so hard to build and the things that we
fight for and the the way that we live
our life I don't think that we want that
to be co-opted or corrupted by this
administration and going to the White
House would be in your opinion risk
co-opting or corrupting your message
yeah I think so I think it's it's an
opportunity first administration to sort
of put us on display as they're you know
sort of guests for the day and I don't
think that that makes sense for for us
at all okay so quick Gretchen she went
to a public high school not a private
high school doesn't change the general
point she's lived a pretty good life she
also said in this interview that she had
an immense sense of pride and
responsibility by kneeling during the
national anthem nothing says pride and
responsibility quite like kneeling
during the national anthem of a country
that has fought for your rights to be an
incredibly famous person based on
kicking a ball and having the proper
leftist messaging also Megan Rapinoe
suggested that she would only meet with
people who agree with her so she said
she would go to DC and have a
substantive conversation with quote
anyone who believes the same things we
believe in yes Wow doing doing amazing
work on behalf of her perspective by
meeting with
people who already agree with her really
really tremendous stuff the best part of
this Megan Rapinoe interview is that she
was asked how fans can support the fight
for equal pay her answer is just
incredible in the moments immediately
following the final whistle you get that
USA USA chant but equal pay equal pay
along that same cadence I think fans
want to know what they can do to support
that fight fans can come to games
obviously the national team games will
be a hot ticket but we have nine teams
in the NWSL you can go to your league
games you can support that way you can
you know buy players jerseys you can
lend your support in that way you can
tell your friends about it you can
become season ticket holders I think in
terms of of that that's the the easiest
way for for fans to get involved oh you
mean that fans can actually create the
economic incentives for you to get paid
more
you mean that capitalism can actually
raise your pay so what you're saying is
that the reason you're not getting equal
pay right now is because you're not
making equal money for your league and
the best way for you to raise your pay
would be for people to come and purchase
tickets and memorabilia from your team
which suggests that this isn't about
sexism at all this is about you just
complaining about sexism for publicity
this sort of stuff and there's no follow
up there at all of course you know in
Rachel Maddow is never gonna do the
follow up that's who's interviewing her
there Rachel Maddow is never going to
say to Megan Rapinoe
so you're saying capitalism can actually
increase your pay now that's never gonna
be a thing that anyone on the left has
instead we all have to pretend that this
is that this is all normal and that it's
not divisive at all and that truly she's
a hero to everyone absolute absolute
silliness absolute silence and bad for
the country by the way when even the
stuff that we take a break with you know
sporting is turned into this it's pretty
obnoxious and we're not talking about
1968 in the middle of the civil rights
movement with with us sprinters on the
u.s. national team at the Olympics
raising the black power fist because
American politics are polarized around
race in 68 we're not talking about that
we're talking about gay marriage is
legal across the United States by
Supreme Court dick taht we were talking
about Megan Rapinoe is getting
million-dollar contracts specifically
because of her sexuality and because she
is a very very good soccer player but
not make any mistake if you were a very
good soccer player and she were not a
very outspoken lesbian she would be
getting fewer contracts because she is
seen as a political figure she's sort of
Colin Kaepernick but with actual talents
at her sport so it's all of this is
obnoxious but we're supposed to pretend
that actually she's quite charming and
wonderful that it is not obnoxious to
live in the most to live in the best
time for women in best time for lesbians
and the best time for women's soccer in
the history of the world and in the best
country in the history of the world for
any of those things we're supposed to
pretend that actually she's a victim in
America's a terrible place so that she
can make more money presumably pretty
gross okay meanwhile quick update on the
on the Jeffrey Epstein story so the
Jeffrey Epstein story there's no real
news that is coming out about it people
are mostly just fulminating over what's
going to happen next so is Bill Clinton
the next shooter drop or is Alex Acosta
the Secretary of Labor the person who is
going to feel the brunt so a couple of
details about the Alexander Acosta
connection that are worthy of note here
some information that people haven't
really been given or people haven't
talked about and that is what exactly
did the labor secretary do when he was
the federal prosecutor and down in Miami
when he was a US Attorney down in Miami
with Jeffrey Epstein so right now people
are calling for a casa to resign because
there seemed to be a sweetheart deal in
2007 between Jeffrey Epstein and Alex
Acosta's office of the US attorney in
Miami and in that in that plea deal more
than that that in the deal Epstein
struck a bargain that included Epstein
pleading guilty to two felony
solicitation charges agreeing to 18
months in prison he eventually served 13
and registering as a sex offender the
deal also closed an ongoing FBI
investigation and kept the case under
seal including by not notifying
Epstein's accusers so it's a really
really good deal for Jeffrey Epstein and
the person who is working at that office
at the time was Alex Acosta who is now
the Secretary of Labor Erin Blake
actually has a really good piece over at
the Washington Post talking about what
Acosta has said in response to all of
this so a Kostas handling of the case
according to Blake has been called into
question before but in December the
Miami Herald published a blockbuster
story revealing potential differential
treatments that a cost and other
prosecutors gave Epstein's lawyer
especially when it came to keeping the
matter private a casa is readily
commented on the matter when he has his
decline to do so in detail sometimes
citing ongoing litigation and a fading
memory he did write a lengthy letter in
2011 and was asked about it in 2017 it
came up in 2018 at a hearing of the
house of propriate subcommittee a casa
census 2011 letter to The Daily Beast in
that letter he suggested that evidence
that came out after the plea deal has
led to some revisionist history he said
some may feel the prosecution should
have been tougher evidence has come to
light since 2007 that may encourage that
view but he said it was the right
decision at the time said I supported
that judgment then based on the state of
the law as it then stood in evidence
known at the time I would support the
judgment again in the 2011 letter Acosta
did this is a detail that matters he
came out strongly against another
controversial aspect of Epstein's
treatment part of the part of the deal
was that Epstein would be able to leave
jail during the day and then return at
night Acosta noted that state
authorities were in charge of that not
federal authorities he added that quote
without doubt the treatment he received
well in state custody undermined the
purpose of the jail sentence in 2017 in
testimony he called that arrangement
awful Acosta also said that Epstein's
lawyers which included Alan Dershowitz
and Ken Starr were ruthless and willing
to dig into the personal lives of
prosecutors he said it was a year-long
assault he said I confess it's been
difficult for him to be cordial with his
opponents after this case he said the
aggressive tactics didn't influence his
decisions one way or another so that has
been Acosta has also said that there was
a a consensus or broadly held
feeling within the prosecutor's office
that the deal was about as good as they
were going to get there was at least one
agent who told the Miami Herald that
people were very disappointed with that
particular deal so I'm sure there will
be more information to come out but it
is worthy of note that Acosta for
example opposed what is obviously the
most lenient part of the sentence which
is Acosta which is Epstein being able to
leave jail during the day and come back
at night meanwhile how deeply is Bill
Clinton's hidin well there's a woman who
is an expert on underage sex trafficking
her name is Conchita Sarnoff she's
actually she runs the foundation based
on it
Cruz asked on Fox News about Bill
Clinton she says there's another shoe to
drop here I know from the pilot logs and
these are pilot logs that you know were
written by different pilots and and
at different times that Clinton went he
was a guest of Clint of Epstein's 27
times almost every time that Clinton's
name is on the pilot logs there are
underage girls
there are initials and there are names
of many many girls on that private plane
so you have to ask yourself why would
anyone not only a former president fly
on a plane 27 times
okay so there's still some other I'm
sure there will be more news to drop
here so we'll keep an eye on all of that
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today so as you know I'm a
devotee of baseball I love baseball this
is one of the best baseball books I have
ever read it is an older book it is from
Daniel Okrent who used to be the one of
the editors over at the New York Times
he's written a couple of really good
baseball books the book is called nine
innings the anatomy of a baseball game
and Okrent takes a 1981 baseball game
between the st. Louis Cardinals and the
Milwaukee Brewers and he breaks it down
out by out and pitch by pitch it's
really good for a baseball fan this
stuff is just nirvana
it's a terrific terrific book I can't
believe I hadn't heard of it before but
it is it is certainly worth the read so
if you're a baseball fan or a sports fan
generally this is about as good as it
gets for baseball books the annual oak
runs nine innings go check it out right
now other things that I like so as I
mentioned yesterday Mitch McConnell had
been hit with an NBC news report that
his great-great grandfather's two of
them were slave owners Wow
going back 150 years and finding
something in the family tree that you
don't like amazing amazing well Mitch
McConnell was asked about this yesterday
and this is about as good as it gets for
cocaine Mitch so cocaine Mitch really
just snortin a line and then going full
Scarface on the reporter in this
particular in this particular exchange
solid stuff from Mitch McConnell
fathers were slave owners in Alabama
before the Civil War and the hostile
revelation caused you to change her
position on reparations
you know I find myself once again in the
same position as President Obama we both
oppose reparations and we both are the
descendants of slaveholders a hundred
percent true mentioned it yesterday on
the show Barack Obama is descended on
his mother's side from slave owners by
the way so it's combo Harris apparently
her dad has written about the fact that
he is descended from slave owners as
well so if this is the way this is going
to work that if somebody in your family
treated something wrong then we are
going to hold you to account good for
Mitch McConnell for doing this that is
solid stuff from you can always tell
Mitch McConnell knows he's getting off a
good line when that slight smile creases
the turtle face and suddenly he is
dropping dropping hot fire on people
pretty good stuff hey time for some
things that I hate so they're a bunch of
candidates who are just hanging around
in this Democratic race who should not
be hanging around in this Democratic
race one of those candidates is beta or
work I remember that time when beta was
a serious candidate when that funny made
over I remember it was really really
hilarious
well now beta O'Rourke is polling it's
sad news for bait oh man he is down all
the way to 2.6 percent in the Real Clear
Politics poll average just beating out
cory booker and Tulsi Gabbard ouch this
is a guy who had raised an enormous
amounts money when he jumped into the
race he was polling at nearly 10% right
back in January when he when he actually
jumped in he was all the way up in some
of the polls to nine nine and a half
percent he was running basically third
in the polls he he'd gotten up to third
in the polls by mid-april it was going
Biden Sanders and then O'Rourke and he
has just fallen off a cliff all the way
down to 2% and now he is relegated to
doing his worst
no I'm Chomsky impersonation Cedars
betta taking a drag bra riding a
skateboard and then talk about how
America's the worst America's terrible
and racist even though he can be a
totally unsuccessful Congress person who
runs for Senate marry into wealth have
an incredibly privileged life go to
Columbia
University it's been like a decade
growing out with your bro-friends and
playing crap gigs around the country
well dressed as a sheep then you can run
for city council Congress Senate lose
and then run for president this country
sucks man and if you're bait oh you know
it sucks because you're talking to
people who are minorities and you assume
they also think it sucks this country
was founded on white supremacy and every
single institution and structure that we
have in our country still reflects the
legacy of slavery and segregation and
Jim Crow and suppression even in our
democracy
yeah I'm sure so it was founded on white
supremacy this is a this is a claim that
you keep hearing from the left and I've
said before I think this is a key divide
in the American mind right now that
there a lot of people mostly on the
right but not entirely who say that
America was founded on good true eternal
principles we haven't always lived up to
those principles but the story of
America is about us establishing grand
and great principles in the Declaration
of Independence and the Constitution of
the United States and then working to
broaden out those principles to apply to
the people to whom they always should
have been applied to but thanks to
cultural standards of the time they were
not fully applied in the line of
thinking of this by the way is Frederick
Douglass right whose speech was quoted
out of context by Colin Kaepernick who
knows as much about history as I do
about blitz packages and Colin
Kaepernick tweeted tweeted and and
quoted Frederick Douglass way out of
context Frederick Douglass has a very
famous speech when he talked about what
the fourth of July meant to the black
person in America he talked about how it
didn't apply to the black person in
America but that's because the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution were Liberty documents that
had not been properly read and had not
been extended out as they should have
been right that is the in that line of
thinking are an enormous number of civil
rights leaders I would say that Martin
Luther King was in this line there's a
reason why Martin Luther King correctly
would use American principles as the
greatest defense to his position and
that was effective that was effective
that's one line of thinking then there's
another line of thinking and that's the
thinking that basically all the grand
and glorious principles of the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution of the United States all
the talk about natural rights and
natural law all of those things is
merely a guy's a guy's for power
politics and this line of thinking there
two particular strains of relevant one
is the economic strain sayers group of
people led in the early 20th century by
a sociologist and historian named
Charles beard that suggested basically
that the founders were a bunch of rich
white dudes and they're trying to
enshrine their rich whiteness by
creating these highfalutin ideals and
then using the highfalutin ideals in
order to push their actual agenda which
was to enshrine their own wealth does
the Charles beard economic analysis of
American history it is not true it is
bad history but nonetheless it has
become very popular to cite from people
ranging from Woodrow Wilson in the early
20th century to Bernie Sanders in the
now and then there's the racial aspect
which says America was founded in white
supremacy that when Thomas Jefferson
wrote all men are created equal he
didn't mean black people which is
actually not really true Thomas
Jefferson did mean black people he just
didn't want to apply it to black people
is why Thomas Jefferson is a really
troubling character in American history
and really symbolizes a lot of the
conflicts of American history Jefferson
knew what he was writing and then he
proceeded to ignore what he was writing
he proceeded to live with the cognitive
dissonance early on in Jefferson's
career he was pretty anti-slavery and
then as he became accustomed to having
his own slaves being a slave holder you
know by most evidence siren children by
Sally Hemings and all of us as he did
that he had customed himself to living
with the cognitive dissonance of
participating in an act of evil that he
knew was actually deeply wrong but do
you suggest that the founders
universally we're pro-slavery is untrue
to suggest the founders universally
didn't think of black people as people
is simply untrue you can you can read
founders including John Adams talking
about all of this nonetheless
nonetheless there is this claim made
that basically what really undergirds
the Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence is white supremacy not that
whiteness and white solidarity and the
grading of other races was common to an
enormous number of people at the time
including in Europe where slavery was
still legal at the time of the
Declaration of Independence in the
Constitution of the United States not
only that but that that was actually at
the root of all of this that the real
root rationale for the founding of the
country was the preservation of white
supremacy now the difference is that we
all live in sort of the cultural swamp
of our times right a hundred years from
now people look back on us in the
as primitives because that's how
everybody has done things for all of
human history I think the area in which
they're most likely to do that is with
regard to the eating of animals I think
that over time and I love eating meat
but I will admit that I think in a
hundred years people are gonna look back
when we have created better meat
substitutes or we've created the ability
to grow protein animal protein without
actually killing animals they'll look
back in a hundred years ago how could
people slaughter our animals like that
right and 100 years people look back at
us they'll certainly do this about
abortion within 30 years people are
gonna look back at us and say wait you
people were arguing you should be able
to kill a baby up until the point of
birth that's what you people were doing
I mean there for those of us are doing
that now but the question is whether
that defines the society or whether that
is just an aspect of the culture that is
taken for granted as sort of the
background noise of the culture and does
that provide the route of the society or
is that just part of the background
noise so it is true that racism was part
of the background noise of society in
1775 that was certainly a huge part of
society undeniably was that what
differentiated America from other places
no differentiated America from other
places is the acknowledgment of those
high ideals when beta or work says
America was founded in white supremacy
what he means is that white supremacy
lay at the root right it was the actual
driving force behind the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution of the
United States and the creation of the
country that's a lie it's not true and
recognizing the shadings of history
recognizing the truth of cultural mores
being different in 1770 than they are in
2019 there is nothing more historically
ignorant or frankly arrogant than
suggesting that you are a better person
than Thomas Jefferson was when you live
in a completely different society than
Thomas Jefferson did I don't know what
you would have done in 1776 you don't
know what you would have done in 1776 he
certainly wouldn't have the same values
that you do now because you weren't
brought up in the same values that
you've been brought up with so the this
sort of pandering ridiculous America is
deeply evil place because in the past
people did bad things
and guess what in 100 years people gonna
look back and think that you were pretty
garbage too so that's that that's the
way this all works this is not unique to
to bethe o'rourke of course the
radicalism of the Democratic Party is
continuing and ugly Elizabeth Warren of
course has gained a lot more
support then they'd only propped up by
media attention so the media have now
given Elizabeth Warren the sort of
attention that they used to give debate
oh they used to suggest the bado
was the golden fair-haired child now
it's Elizabeth Warren who is the golden
fair-haired grandmother and she
apparently has all the ideas and all the
solutions she is deeply radical on a
variety of issues not least including
the Middle East she has one advisor
named Max Berger who is supremely
radical on this issue he has sympathized
in the past with terrorists with
Palestinian terrorists in the Gaza Strip
his malign the Israeli government is
committing pogroms he's really really
bad and he's her top foreign policy
adviser Elizabeth Warren was asked
yesterday at some event about whether
she would commit to ending Israel's
so-called occupation now for those who
don't know about the quote-unquote
occupation basically Israel in 1967 was
attacked by a variety of Arab nations
Jordan Egypt Syria they all attacked
Saudi Arabia they all attacked right
before they attacked Israel launched a
preemptive strike and blew up the
egyptian air force on the tarmac and the
six-day war Israel ends up winning a
huge swath of land including Judea and
Samaria which is the historic heart of
biblical Israel they include they
unified Jerusalem the Israelis they take
the Gaza Strip
now when you launch a war and then you
lose the territory typically you don't
get to claim that it is an occupied
territory that's silly towns but in any
case the UN creates a resolution UN
resolution 242 which suggests that
Israel has to give up occupied
territories right not the occupied
territories occupied territories now the
reason that it leaves out the word the
is because some of those territories are
given up and some of those areas are
maintained Israel no longer occupies if
that's a word you want to use the Gaza
Strip Israel pulled out of the Gaza
Strip in 2005 they in fact forcibly
removed all Jews from Gush Katif
in 2005 since then it has been
completely run by the terrorist group
Hamas the Israelis have nothing to do
with it except they prevent the
importation of weaponry and they prevent
people terrorists from crossing the
border and in the Palestinian areas in
the so-called West Bank Judea and
Samaria the vast majority of the
Palestinian population lives under
direct Palestinian governance again
Israel police's the borders to make sure
the weapons aren't being shipped in but
the so-called the occupation Israeli
soldiers are not wandering around in
Mahwah that is all run by the
Palestinian Authority nonetheless here's
Elizabeth Warren suggesting that Israel
is an occupying force despite all of
that history and despite the truth which
that the Palestinian Authority is a
terrorist entity Hamas as a terrorist
entity they steal the money of their
citizens they treat their citizens like
garbage and in the last elections which
were like 2005 for Hamas 2006 for Hamas
in 2007 for the Palestinian Authority
those terrorist groups were re-elected
in a landslide here is Elizabeth Warren
completely botching the history but
she's radically left so she doesn't have
to know history ok those those women by
the way work for a group called if not
now which is an extraordinarily radical
anti-israel group that basically
considers all Israel's very existence
nearly illegitimate if not now is a
terrible terrible group the the
constantly stumping in favor of boycott
divestment and sanctions from Israel
which is an anti-semitic policy they've
stumped in favor of Hamas is use of
civilian shields in the Gaza Strip
they're really bad there's a Lizabeth
warrant a pandering as hard as she
possibly can this is the new democratic
party this is the new democratic party
shout out to one member of the
Democratic Party by the way who actually
said a true thing Tulsi Gabbard who is
getting a little bit of attention but
probably not enough based on her pretty
decent debate performance Tulsi Gabbard
said something true I know it's always a
shock to me she said that Kamala Harris
was pandering I'm bussing that it was
all a ploy that the federal bussing
employ was a bunch of nonsense this is
true this this accusation that Joe Biden
is racist when he's clearly not as a way
to try to smear him and as you point to
the article that I linked to in my tweet
really what she's saying is her position
is the same one that she was criticizing
Joe Biden for so this is just a
political ploy and I think a very
underhanded one just to try to get
herself attention to move herself up in
the polls I think I think that we need
to be above that all of us okay a
hundred percent true Tulsi Gabbard for
the win right there that is 100 percent
correct by the way it is it is Elizabeth
Moore
and it is Komal Harris's inability to go
more than five minutes without switching
a position or lying or being overtly
political that is leading to her not
actually benefiting as much as she
probably should be from her debate
performance Elizabeth Warren instead
continues to run by most polls in second
place this is a four-person race at best
probably a three person race probably
Elizabeth Warren Kamala Harris Joe Biden
alrighty well we will be back here a
little bit later today for two
additional hours of content so be there
or be square over at Daily wire comm I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everyone its Andrew Klavan host
of the Andrew Clavin show abused
children they only become news when the
left can use them for political purposes
if they can attack Trump's attempts to
secure the border or give the Catholic
Church a bad name or take out a
Republican candidate who did something
wrong but when it comes to the
persistent organized sexual abuse of
underage girls and boys the story always
dies let's keep an eye on this epstein
case and see where it goes on the Andrew
Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clavin